grosse désillusion pour les moins de 16
ans des templiers d'elancourt les saint
quentinois se sont inclinés ce dimanche
40 à 12 en quart de finale des playoffs
au complexe sportif europe contre les
quarks une équipe estonienne la saison
des élans pour toi est terminée on a
fait beaucoup trop de fautes pour
pouvoir espérer gagner le match c'est
beaucoup de turnover de l'interception d
erreur d'alignement débloque pas fait
c'est beaucoup de choses pour gagner un
match c'est impossible
pour expliquer cette défaite les cadres
pointe le manque de rigueur aux
entraînements ces dernières semaines
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont à venir
entraînements et qui viennent au match
pour m'entraîner ben c'est en commun que
les dernières semaines d'entraînement
c'était pas du tout ça on n'avait pas
nos joueurs qu'il fallait il ya eu la
période de vacances c'est pas une excuse
certes des quarks et si on est là en
vacances mais pendant deux semaines
n'avait pas l'effectif est complet on
mettait des joueurs un peu partout pour
compléter les troncs c'est pas comme ça
qu'on fait par un mac docteur relancer
cette saison la section u16 soit
reconduit l'année prochaine
les objectifs sont revus à la hausse
garder un maximum les joueurs garder
l'effectif qu'on a pensé non prochaine
c'est de continuer
pourquoi pas lors des demi finales 5
cette saison la section des moins deux
saisons des templiers d'elancourt 30 et
35 inscrits